RADHA MATHUR:
Hello, and welcome.
I'm Radha Mathur.
I'm a product manager
at Google Cloud.
And in this session, I will be
presenting an overview of HA
and data protection on GCP.
We'll go over the catalog
of HA and data protection
capabilities for both IaaS and
PaaS workloads running on GCP.
And I'm happy to share that I
will be joined by Jeremy Tinley
from Etsy, who has
graciously agreed
to describe how Etsy uses
and benefits from some
of these capabilities.
Let's get started.
HA and data protection
solutions are
required to maintain
business continuity.
Key business
continuity objectives
are to guard against
accidental data loss
due to user errors, data
corruption, or ransomware,
and to achieve resilience
to infrastructure failures,
such as zone failures,
competence failures,
or even failures
of entire regions
that could be caused
by natural disasters.
Common HA and data
protection solutions
that enable business
continuity include
backups, cross-zone
high availability,
and cross-region replication
and DR orchestration.
These solutions form a
spectrum with respect
to the level of resiliency that
they provide and their cost.
And the choice of any one
solution for a workload
depends on the business
criticality of the workload
as well as the tolerance of
that workload to downtime.
For example, workloads that can
tolerate a higher recovery time
could employ backups
for protection
against both user errors
and infrastructure failures.
Whereas mission
critical workloads
that have stringent
uptime requirements
would typically use
replication-based solutions
for protection from
infrastructure failures,
and in addition to that
use backups for protection
from user errors.
Now, irrespective of where your
workload is in this spectrum,
our goal at GCP is to provide
a rich catalog of built-in data
protection primitives as
well as ISP partner products
to help design a
business continuity
solution that is aligned with
the needs of your business.
GCP Compute, Storage,
and many PaaS services
offer a wide range of
replication and backup
capabilities.
These primitives serve
as building blocks
that can help you form a
business continuity solution.
In addition to that, we have a
rich ecosystem of ISP partner
products that augment the
primitives available on GCP
and support a wide
variety of use cases,
from protecting GCE VMs,
to enterprise applications
such as SAP, to
replicating entire VMware
environments from on-premises
to GCP for disaster recovery.
Various protection
mechanisms can
be employed for protecting
application workloads running
on GCP-managed infrastructure.
Let's take a deeper look
at some of these HA data
protection primitives.
To achieve high availability
in the event of infrastructure
unavailability such
as zone failure,
VMs and Containers
can be distributed
across zones in a region.
Similarly, both
persistent disk and GCS
offer regional instances
that replicate data
across zones in a region.
Capabilities such as VM machine
images and persistent disk
snapshots enabling backing up
of both VM configuration as well
as application data.
And similar backup
capabilities are
in the pipeline for Anthos
GKE Clusters as well
as Cloud Filestore.
Georedundant Cloud Storage
skews help replicate data
across regions for
disaster recovery.
And DR orchestration is
enabled by Deployment Manager.
Now, in addition to compute
and storage primitives,
we're adding primitives
in the near future
to aid in application-consistent
backups such as persistent disk
app-consistent snapshot hooks
and SAP-certified backint
agents for Google Cloud Storage.
GCP PaaS databases and
analytics services also
pack in a rich set of
replication and backup
capabilities.
Managed databases such as Cloud
Spanner and Cloud Bigtable
offer modes for cross-zone
and cross-region replication.
Cloud SQL HA instances
and Google BigQuery
regional instances
provide high availability
against zone failures.
For data backups, PaaS databases
on GCP offer primitives
such as managed backups as well
as the ability to export data
in industry standard formats.
Cloud SQL also enables granular
recovery from user errors
or application corruption
via a point-in-time recovery.
Having looked at primitives
suited for IaaS and PaaS
workloads running
on GCP, let's look
at how one of our customers is
using GCP's business continuity
primitives as building blocks in
their data protection strategy.
I'm pleased to welcome
Jeremy Tinley, senior staff
engineer on Etsy's database
infrastructure team,
to share insights
from their production
strategy for etsy.com.
Welcome, Jeremy.
JEREMY TINLEY: Thanks, Radha.
I've been at Etsy for six
years, and over that time,
the infrastructure has
considerably evolved.
We recently migrated
to Google Cloud,
and this gave us a chance
to rethink our general DR
strategy.
Google Cloud offers a wide range
of services for DR. Selecting
and, more importantly, adopting
them was very important to us.
But first, a little
bit about Etsy.
Etsy is a global
online marketplace
where people come together to
make, sell, buy, and collect
unique items.
So who sells on Etsy?
Etsy sellers are people
from all over the world.
They use their incredible
talent to make things.
This can be blankets made in
Morocco, jewelry from Ecuador,
or even soap made in Seattle.
They can also be people
who have vintage items
that they're finally
willing to part with.
On the flip side of the
marketplace, you have buyers.
Etsy buyers browse
the marketplace
looking for items based
on personal style or need.
My current favorite is buying
handmade chocolate truffles.
I usually buy them
locally made from somebody
who's in my community,
who's my neighbor.
And that also helps because
the shipping is really quick.
My favorite thing
about Etsy, though,
is that they enable a
human-to-human connection.
You're not buying
something from a warehouse.
You're buying it
from a human being.
Working at Etsy
is a bit similar.
Humans are crafting
infrastructure and code.
Hence our phrase, code is craft.
With that, let's review
our architecture.
Etsy is a traditional LAMP stack
consisting of Linux, Apache,
MySQL, and PHP.
Since Etsy is an
e-commerce marketplace,
you can probably imagine
a typical interaction
with the website.
A seller lists new
items by entering
in the name, the
pricing, and description.
Buyers browsing Etsy get to
read the seller's content.
They can initiate a
conversation with the seller,
asking them questions
about their products.
They add an item to their cart,
and hopefully, they purchase.
After they've made
a purchase, they
can track the shipping status.
And when they
receive their item,
they can leave ratings and
feedback for the store.
Both the front-end
and back-end services
run on Google Compute Engine
VMs, not on a hosted platform.
We do this because
we want more hands
on control over the systems.
On the front-end, we use
managed instance groups
to maintain availability
of web and API servers.
This makes it trivial to
add or remove capacity,
and failing servers are
depooled automatically.
Our front-end workloads
are stateless,
and this makes it
straightforward to manage
disaster recovery.
Moving to the
back-end, however, is
where things get complicated.
From the description
above, you can
surmise that we run a
traditional OLTP workload.
All of the data that buyers and
sellers generate and interact
with is stored in MySQL.
From a DR point of
view, we primarily
rely on MySQL native replication
for multiple copies of data.
We execute periodic snapshots
of our data, and for each one,
we run a restore test
process to validate it.
For transaction logs, we sync
those to Google Cloud Storage
buckets on a scheduled basis.
However, our world wasn't
always so wonderful.
Etsy is 15 years old,
and for most of that,
it was hosted in a traditional
datacenter with bare metal
servers.
The good news about running
your own data center--
you can manage everything.
The bad news-- you have
to manage everything.
So let's look at one
specific case dealing
with hardware failure.
I think we can all agree that
computers are both amazing
and also terrible.
Hardware failures,
especially disks, happen.
This meant that we needed to
be able to rebuild servers
as the need arose.
This was especially painful
when dealing with large amounts
of data in MySQL.
The first step was just to
provision a bare metal server.
On a good day, an
hour was optimistic.
On a bad day, we would fight
with UEFI settings, boot disk
issues, and Anaconda
was not a good friend.
Let's assume that all that
goes correctly, though.
After we've built our
bare mental server,
we have to restore MySQL data.
We copy our data
over the network,
decrypt and decompress it, bring
a database online, and wait
for replication to catch up.
Although it was all
automated, it still
took a long time to perform--
many hours.
This same slow down translated
to our backup process.
We ran into a longer than
desired RTO, or recovery
time objective.
Our MySQL data backups
were being performed daily.
Backups took about
three hours to complete,
which for us was painfully slow.
These backups were full
backups sent over a network
to specific backup
servers that had
lots of disk loaded in them.
However, the process
doesn't end there.
As the old adage goes,
a backup isn't a backup
until it's been tested.
Once our backup was transferred,
a restore test process
was kicked off to verify that
the data could be recovered.
This involved once again
copying the full backup
over the network to
restore testing server,
decrypting and decompressing,
bringing the database online,
and waiting for
replication to catch up.
As I said before,
that whole process
took multiple hours to achieve.
When these problems
are magnified at scale,
both for the amount of
data and copies of data,
it begins to stress
the infrastructure.
Etsy ran many, many
copies of data,
each with a different purpose.
We have our main production
workload that has redundancy.
We have geographic redundancy.
And others were
artificially delayed
to allow faster online
recovery in the event
of an inadvertent data change.
Thankfully, late in 2018, we
migrated Etsy to Google Cloud.
In our relatively
new cloud world,
we found easier solutions
to these problems.
As I said earlier,
the front-end takes
advantage of managed
instance groups
to improve the speed at which
failed nodes are replaced.
The host is failed.
The host is destroyed.
And it's rebuilt. The host is
added back to production when
it's registered as healthy.
Before this magic, disks
would have to be replaced.
Hosts would have to
be rebuilt by hand.
No one even has to pay attention
to these issues anymore.
This frees them up to focus
on other areas of improvement.
Our new MySQL
environment was designed
to take advantage of native
Google Cloud features.
The big shift was to use
persistent disks instead
of local disks.
We built our databases
with one boot disk
for logs and state data, like
PID files and lock files.
The second disk is
only for MySQL data.
Performing a live disk
snapshot in MySQL is--
no pun intended-- a snap.
There's no need to
quiesce a database either.
When MySQL starts up,
it's treated like a crash,
and it recovers itself.
By using persistent disks,
we got very easy differential
backups with PD snapshots.
And coming from the world
where we did full backups
every single day, this improved
our backup times from two
to three hours down
to three minutes.
We can now take many snapshots
per day, giving us the ability
to roll back data to
previously known good point.
This eliminated the need
for an online delayed copy.
Also, our snapshots
are multi-region,
so we no longer have to
manage shipping full backups
across the entire US.
Or restore test
process is similar
as it was before,
with some wins.
After we obtain a snapshot,
we again do a restore test.
However, this time in GCP we're
able to provision a new VM
dynamically.
We create and attach a
new disk from a snapshot.
We bring MySQL fully online
and have it replicating.
By taking more
frequent snapshots,
replication catch up time
was significantly reduced.
This process used
to run for hours.
We can now test a copy of
data in just 15 minutes.
Another big win was to
use Google Cloud Storage.
We consistently
send our transaction
logs to a bucket with
Lifecycle Management enabled.
This helps us maintain
a retention policy that
makes sense for our use case,
including automatic purging
of files when they age off.
And let me tell you, legal is
really happy with that one.
Our buckets are
also multi-regional,
giving us geographic
redundancy with our backups,
just like our snapshots.
All of this translates to
stress-free disaster recovery.
Recapping our results, we saw a
big benefit with our migration
to Google Cloud.
Front-end server builds are
much faster, and automatic.
On the back-end, we see a
tremendous improvement in RTO,
both the speed at
which we can provision,
down to how quickly the
data can be brought online.
I think we've just scratched the
surface with what's possible.
We plan on looking
at additional DR
services that can be leveraged
to make our life easier.
These results might
have been possible
in a traditional
datacenter, but it
would require additional
staffing, infrastructure,
and capacity management.
As someone who participates
in an on-call rotation,
I'm quite happy to offload those
challenges to Google Cloud.
RADHA MATHUR: Thanks, Jeremy,
for the insightful description
of the impact you've seen by
use of HA and data protection
primitives as part
of your GCP stack.
From backup of data disks,
to replication of transaction
logs, to use of highly-available
managed instance groups for web
servers, the solution
shared by Jeremy
is representative of how
primitives across the spectrum
can be used for different
components of your workload
based on the needs
of your business.
This concludes our overview
of HA and data protection
capabilities on GCP.
Thank you for joining us.